diese bilder stammen nicht aus den alpen
sondern von der adria
snowboard stadt surfbrett heißt es
aktuell in rimini an der mittelmeerküste
tummeln sich normalerweise im sommer
tausende touristen jetzt ist alles weiß
der winter hat sich breitgemacht ein
eher ungewöhnliches bild ein heftiger
schneesturm ist über das italienische
sommerparadies hinweggefegt die stadt im
nordosten des landes ist kaum
wiederzuerkennen
die kilometerlangen strände an denen
sich sonst touristen in kurzen klamotten
tummeln laden nun zu winterlichen
spaziergang samt mütze und schal ein
schnee in rimini das ist selten und
deshalb wollen es viele anwohner auch
unbedingt für die nachwelt festhalten
[Musik]
die einheimischen machen also das beste
draus und genießen das naturspektakel
zum glück können sie das surfbrett ja im
sommer wieder im wasser benutzen